we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we heard
today from the eggman calling in about
yesterday's voicemail take a listen to
this
dave your caller on wednesdays so
opening statement was he's a homeless
guy in california
I thought it was our buddy ditch Darrell
and then it took him to be a crazy guy
but he watches youtube all the time and
he's homeless Dave I was homeless in
California I had a pager and a van I
didn't have YouTube as being homeless
and having YouTube and a cell phone is a
pretty cool way to be homeless and
marijuana is legal maybe this guy should
hook up with that ditch Daryl guy and
you know help each other out
but um anyway homeless guys in
California are batting 500 now instead
of that in 2000
oh well Shalom brother yeah so the
eggman is referring I don't know if this
predates you Pat but there was a guy
homeless Daryl or Daryl in a ditch or
diabetic Daryl who would call in and
people loved him the eggman loved him
and I guess with the eggman saying is he
prefers homeless Daryl to yesterday's
homeless California caller I tend to
resist these ideas of like the cool ways
to be homeless I understand that being
homeless in place a might be not as bad
as being homeless in place be in the
same way that I understand that today
almost everyone would be considered
filthy rich if you go back to like 5,000
years ago that's not a good reason to
not care about the conditions of poor
people in the United States
just cuz 5000 years ago you would have
been in great shape compared to people
who were bathing every once a month that
doesn't mean that now we shouldn't care
or seek to improve conditions so we love
the eggman but I quite frankly don't
know what the hell he's talking about
we've got a great bonus show for you
today that I do know we will talk about
Duncan Hunter who is in an embarrassing
situation and much more access the bonus
show by becoming a member on our website
or by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show